recently entertainment Giants IMG and
William Morris Endeavor purchased the
UFC or as it's known to all of us
Ultimate Fighting Championship for four
billion dollars is a big big story right
there Wow big story yeah one of the
biggest transactions in the entire
history of sports now here's the deal
true story I happen to be represented by
William Morris Endeavor okay
and they do these guys do a terrific job
thanks to them as of this morning I am
the new spokesman for the blackberry and
SeaWorld so they do a bang-up job
yelling anywho after the UFC deal was
announced
WME William Morris Endeavor gave some of
their clients an opportunity to purchase
a small ownership stake in the UFC and
I'm excited to announce that I was one
of those clients they call you I I think
I have $40 worth yeah anyway I said yes
and doh so I now technically I own a
piece of the UFC I am now part of a
group of investors that includes Ben
Affleck Tom Brady Mark Wahlberg Adam
Levine Cam Newton LL Cool J Maria
Sharapova Serena Williams Sylvester
Stallone just to name a very few yeah
that's nice
[Applause]
I want to say I'm very honored to be a
part of this group I really am but I
want to make something clear okay the
main reason I bought an ownership stake
in the UFC is not to just be an owner
okay and stand in the background I
bought in because I Conan O'Brien intend
to fight in the Octagon you just saw you
guys just saw me in that say yeah that I
just did with Kevin Hart you see what
I'm packing exactly okay thank you for
the sarcastic wooing no this is a
lifelong dream of mine and I'm told
there's no better time to start fighting
than middle age oh yeah yeah and listen
when I get in the ring these are gonna
be I mean yes it ufc's big now but when
I start fighting in the Octagon right
people gonna lose their [ __ ] yeah people
are gonna go crazy for example and this
is true it's all set up on January 5th I
will be fighting Conor McGregor look
[Applause]
yes yeah that's true then a little later
on February 28th I will be fighting
Ronda Rousey I will yeah then on May
17th I'll be fighting fellow UFC
investor Maria and the day after that my
memorial service will be available
[Applause]
five you can you can mourn at home or
you can go to your local sports bar more
and more nine anyway I'm excited about
this and wait'll you see what I've got
under the hood
that was not appropriate
where do you see what I've got under the
hood anyway for more information go to
ufc.com it's all very exciting and I'm
gonna die I really
[Applause]
okay looks dirty what we're doing yeah
like that you have seen
[Laughter]
you